this happened earlier in the week and we
saved this just for you we could have
done it yesterday but i wanted your
expert analysis
of the comments that tom brady provided
to james corden
of the late late show riding around in a
golf cart here's the conversation that
they had that made a little bit of a
buzz yesterday morning
do you ever think what more have i got
to do in the sport
you know it's hard to walk away from
something that um you know you still
feel like you can do and you want to do
so it's not about proving it to others
right what you could do it's more about
proving it to yourself and i still feel
like even i'll be 44 this year i still
have a chance to
still
you know prove it to myself that i can
still do a 44 because i've really
worked
to a point where i can you know still do
it at this age there's one thing being
like
really good at something there's
something else about being the greatest
of all time how often do you think about
them
i don't really no because they don't
never you never sit and think uh what i
do
i'm the best
it's like saying uh
you know what do you like better steak
fish chicken i mean everything's good
yeah
yes uh look two things said there by tom
brady first he's no longer doing it for
others he's doing it for himself he's no
longer trying to prove anyone wrong he's
trying to prove to himself that he can
play and then also he never thinks about
being the best of all time i submit that
both
are
are not a true indication of how he
actually believes your thoughts okay so
let's let's break it down piece by piece
i would say the proving it to himself
part i believe that i believe that
because
last season he was proving it to
everyone else he was proving to bill
belichick he was proving it to
you know the patriots organization he
was proving it to everyone that thought
tom brady was in decline here he is
winning his seventh super bowl so that
part i kind of buy that this is now he's
done it all you know what i mean he's if
he beats the the patriots and what is it
week four this year he will have beaten
every single team in the nfl he'll have
won seven super bowls he's done it all
the legacy part yeah i i would imagine
that he probably does like to be
referred as the goat
but it's also like he kind of has that
right now
it's almost unassailable
so he's in a position where he can sort
of say
i don't think about that type of stuff
right
now i still think that he thinks about
it and i think he continues to be driven
by the fact that if you haven't heard he
was a sixth round pick in 2000 any
actual or perceived slight he's at the
point where it's so baked into who he is
he uses anything he can to continue to
get his old ass out of bed every morning
to do all the things that he needs to do
and to refrain from doing the things
that he would like to do more often you
get to a point where you say you know
what life's too short to not have a
hamburger life's too short to not have a
beer why am i doing all this avocado ice
cream crap just so i can keep playing
football at some point i want to enjoy
my life so i really do think that he
needs that external kick
to get him to continue to live the life
that he's been living to allow him to
play as long as he has
and let's be honest here mike the the
people who are at the top of their
profession in sports
uh you know go go through the whole list
they're legitimate psychopaths like
that's not and that's not i'm not trying
to take a knock on tom brady he is a
competitive psychopath michael jordan
was the same kobe bryant like peyton
manning you know peyton manning's uh
preparation was legendary so all these
guys
they spend so much time
at the top of their at the top of their
profession competing
studying getting ready getting their
bodies ready lebron james says he puts
like a million dollars into his body a
year what that million dollars buys i
don't know but start asking some
questions maybe people
but the point is all these guys they're
not normal they are not uh in in any way
they're not just like us they are they
are driven by uh wanting to be the best
their competitive nature is off the
charts that would make any of us like
you just said maybe you want to have a
hamburger no they don't they really
don't they want to win at all costs and
that cost is probably
regular life hap you know happiness and
how it looks to us whether it be like
sitting down and watching tv at night or
playing video games or not going to the
gym whatever happiness is they are on
the other side of all of this they find
happiness in raising the lombardi trophy
raising a trophy at the end of the year
and everything they do in in the process
of that
if we looked at it and like wrote it
down like
how you're not living your life man what
are you doing but that's what drives
them that's what makes them crazy
and and it really is amazing sims and i
were talking about this earlier in the
week
the payoff the chance of getting that
payoff
is so slim and it's so driven by factors
out of your control no matter how few
hamburgers you eat no matter how early
you get up no matter what you do
every season comes down to a handful of
fluke plays whether or not a good
decision or a bad decision is made a bad
call a good call bounce of an oblong
ball this way or that way i mean
i think we may have talked about this
last friday i know sims and i've been
talking about it how differently we
would view tom brady's 2020 season if
the packers were able to capitalize on
three straight interceptions by brady
when he was having a meltdown in the
second half of that game in green bay
when the bucks were up 28 to 10. so you
put all that in
for just the chance
to be in the vicinity
of all the crazy stuff that has to go
down to decide who the champion is it
just shows the true
dedication to the point of obsession
and and again i don't think that
obsession gets fueled simply by
i want to prove this to myself i think
at some level it has to be driven by
people still doubt me people still
don't properly respect me former
quarterbacks like chris sims to still
rank me 10th in the league anything he
can find
to keep going because it is such a
narrow window that he's trying to get
through every year
yeah and and but i what about the goat
talk that he said i actually kind of
believe him on that one because
he is
like the greatest of all time
quarterback right now he has seven super
bowls i don't know i don't think that
will ever be topped so until someone
starts sniffing around in his
neighborhood i don't think that he
really cares because he knows that
people will be like well he's got seven
you know what i mean
so
i like
let's do let's do this with an example
right last dance comes out last dance
comes out last summer why has it come
out because
lebron james is starting to at least get
on the block of michael jordan and
that's when he starts saying i care
about this stuff i care about the legacy
i want to remind everyone who i am tom
brady right now doesn't need to remind
people of who he is that the
conversation is over as of right now in
20 years he will probably care if
patrick mahomes has four
five he will probably start carrying a
lot more and trying to insert himself
back into this conversation reminding
everyone hey i'm tom brady but as it
stands right now he has he doesn't need
to say i'm the greatest of all time
because other people will say it for him
the only way that i'm willing to accept
that he's not thinking that he's the
greatest of all time
is that in his mind he still has more
work to do
so now is not the time to have those
thoughts to have that discussion i still
have more work to do
the the book isn't finished yet so
for if that's what he would say
i'd be inclined to believe it but then
he goes into this it's kind of like what
do you prefer steak chicken or fish and
james corden in his own hilarious way
called him out on it of course you're
going to choose steak over chicken or
fish so you know he he know brady knows
you don't have to maybe that's it he
doesn't have to think about it because
he knows he just knows right that's my
point i think about it right that's my
point he knows right now if if if in 15
20 years patrick mahomes is on his block
he it will be a different discussion
altogether and it will be like hey
remember who i am
and doing all these like interviews and
everything but right now he knows and
everyone else does the legwork for him
when it comes to debate shows and media
like it just kind of it just happens
right like seven seven super bowls
that's i've actually had a few moments
in the last week where i said seven i
was like wait is it seven that's crazy
because it is kind of like it's an
insurmountable amount we know how hard
it is to win a super bowl we know that
what it that you know what it takes to
get to that level and do it seven times
is ridiculous
the fact that he's taken a team there 10
times and the margins were so thin the
closest one
uh
well now this they were all three until
the rams win
by 10 but it felt closer than that this
year was a blowout although it didn't
feel like a blowout because it always
felt like the chiefs were going to find
a gas pedal at some point and roar back
into the game but it just shows you how
hard it is it's just another example of
how difficult you work and you work and
you work and you climb and you get to
the very top and it's still
a herculean effort to plant the flag in
the summit and he just keeps coming back
and doing it that's why i don't think
mahomes is going to catch him i think
mahomes
wants to i think he's talented enough to
do it but look at the last three years
2018.
now if if they win a coin flip in
overtime
maybe they get a chance to go face the
rams in the super bowl no guarantee
they're going to win that game the rams
beat the chiefs in the regular season
2019 they're down 10 points with seven
minutes left had to pull a rabbit out of
his butt to win that game against the
49ers just to get one
and then last year by the time they got
to the super bowl they had nothing left
in the tank
physically to match up with the
buccaneers and it was tom brady who's
been there and done that nine times
before which i think was a major factor
but you know three years of excellence
with one super bowl to show for it you
got plenty of work to do if you're going
to get to seven and you may have to get
to eight by the time it's all said and
done maybe nine by the time brady's
finished playing in the nfl look at
aaron rodgers aaron rodgers gonna i mean
there's a there's a better it's more
likely than not that aaron rodgers will
retire with one super bowl and he won it
very early in his career and never got
you know that second suit never got back
to the super bowl right yeah right so
it's it's that hard to do the football
is
you know the ultimate team sport it's
it's very very hard to get up to the top
of that you need a special season and
you need like you just said a lot of
breaks to go your way the ball to bounce
your way because that's that really is
kind of what it comes down to there's
usually every year in the nfl season
there's four to five teams that are
super bowl caliber worthy and then it's
kind of comes down to who's who plays at
the right time who's healthy at the
right time who has a couple breaks that
go their way at the right time
as it relates to brady
what i mentioned earlier how differently
we would be thinking of him if the
packers had won
the nfc championship after brady's
meltdown in the second half and
the the one thing that i keep an eye on
because yes brady was phenomenal last
year you can't take that away from him
but
he's been for maybe three years now into
the duck and cover phase of his career
for good reason he's trying to preserve
his body that is about to be 44 years
old as of august the 3rd he sees guys
coming at him who are half his age and
twice his size
and his mo is get rid of the ball and
hit the deck bottom line so
you know
when does that reach a critical mass
where he can no longer get rid of the
ball before he gets blown up and
how many of those does it take before
it's it's irrevocably
changed for him i i i was told this four
years ago speaking of holding up the
four
watch the legs not the arm the arm will
be fine into his 50s it's the legs it's
the legs when he can no longer get away
from the guys who are trying to pummel
him and he starts getting hit he's going
to get hurt and he's going to quickly
say i'm too old for this crap
and and that's the thing i keep watching
for
and and look at you know some of the the
miscues from the nfc championship it's
driven by the walls are closing in and
i'm getting rid of this football before
i take a big hit from somebody who
literally is half my age yeah and you
saw it uh i you know the big stat i i
kept going to last year was when the
bucks had you know ali marpit was out
for a little bit they were a completely
different team and they got blown up you
know tom brady didn't have the time up
the middle and he wasn't able to elude
the rush that you know sunday night game
when the saints beat the bucks by a
billion that he was out for that game so
the offensive line holding up for the
bucks
i it has to be the number one priority
every single season as long as tom brady
is there
absolutely and up the middle is the key
we saw that template in the 2007 season
in super bowl 42 when the patriots were
on the brink of going 19-0 and what
happened the giants pressure up the
middle the jets pressure up the middle
in the 2010 division around the giants
pressure up the middle in super bowl 46
that's why hey of all the teams in the
nfc i worry about washington from the
standpoint of the buccaneers because
they're they've got the guys
on the front four and in the front seven
if they get another crack at brady in a
single elimination setting and you could
argue that was one of the toughest games
they had in the postseason last year the
wild card round you know and the
washington offense wasn't good enough to
really take advantage of what the
defense was able to do but
look
news flash he ain't getting any younger
and the longer he keeps going and he's
made it very clear he's got at least two
more years in him at some point father
time always undefeated is going to get
the victory and we just assume
that this is going to continue
indefinitely just like your jacket is
indefinitely lost there will be a
definite end for tom brady the question
is does he do it on his own or is that
decision forced upon him by an opponent
who hits him so hard that he just
realizes i gotta go
yeah but i'm i'm done i i retired from
predicting when it was over for tom
brady years ago because
there's certain people in the media who
every year they're like this is it this
is over
in one year they will be right
yeah one year they will be right but
they were wrong for the last seven years
so i i don't know i just he he's he's
completely broken the rules to how long
you can play this sport and and
obviously the the changes in the rules
for the nfl has helped him a lot like i
don't think if this was 1999 he wouldn't
be playing as a 44 year old because you
can hit the quarterback a lot
differently but now that the game has
changed to a point where you can survive
an entire season without taking those
punishing blows so i don't know mike
like if you told me right now put your
life on it tom brady's not going to be
playing when he's 50 years old i
wouldn't put my life on it
i wouldn't
look
no
as long as he can continue to find a way
to get rid of the football
and any and if his team is willing to
tolerate the interceptions that will
flow from it and the buccaneers are as
long as he can get them close to the top
of the mountain i mean they went from
2002 to
2020
with teams that were not nearly as good
as what they had last year with brady's
influence and that's the thing the value
is his influence his attitude how he
rubs off on his teammates how he gets
them to focus on what's important and
they listen to him he's got the rings
he's got the credentials they'll listen
to him so as long as he can physically
do it i think he will keep doing it and
i i can't rule out him playing until
he's 50 and and again i think he's going
to be driven not by proving it to
himself but by and i think we're also
getting to the point where and i think
this is an important consideration he's
done it for so long what the hell else
does he do he's done it for more than
half of his life
what is he going to do you don't need to
go get a job you got more money than you
can ever spend where are you going to
get your fulfillment where you're going
to get there's nothing else in life
that that rewards you
with this beautiful trophy at the end of
every year
and you know an objective indication of
what you've accomplished in the form of
a piece of jewelry that you can put on
your hands and wave around there's
nothing else that does that how does he
replace that for the rest of his life
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports